[Music]
now shut him again
now jump on him
yeah with both feet
jump on him renee i have heels on
i can't jump on him no no no
he's daddy he doesn't feel laughing
is it true you'll be shooting a remake
of a french silent field that is true
i'll be irma bev renee vidal is
directing juanes
he's nuts in a good way
i'm so sick of being a superhero
i don't need a hit i need a good movie
are you gay i was but not anymore i got
bored with gay culture they are all
communists
how do you handle all the girls around
you
i love you and then you just told me
lori let you like a puppet she ended up
getting what you wanted i must have been
the last person to find out about you
and herman because you're scary and you
scared me
am i that dangerous you are irma vepe
for me so yes you are dangerous
this is not my world peres renee
remember
uh
foreign
i feel i'm focused i have you wrapped
around my finger and lonely
therma is not happening
i have to be on my vet no
you have to let irma that be you
[Music]
you